when you're an addiction you are
isolated you're cutting yourself off
from every relationship to any
meaningful Communications with people
any connection whatsoever and then it's
like oh I wonder why I'm drinking myself
to death and using myself or doing
whatever to death and it's like because
what else have you got going on
[Music]
so I'm Joe
um I'm in recovery from my gambling
addiction and I haven't gambled now for
two years I'm Patrick I'm also
recovering a compulsive Gambler I've
been in recovery for five years now hi
my name's Thomas I'm also in recovery
particularly from ketamine for almost
five years and I'm also a public speaker
yeah my name is Colin I'm a recover in
heroin addict I've been clean for three
years now so yeah hi I'm Janet I call
myself an addict because I was addicted
to sleeping pills and just self-harm and
things like that but also my main thing
was alcohol I got sober at 20 and I'm
now 28. hey I'm Eliza I'm a business
owner and Instagram influencer person
um
I'm an alcoholic and addict
my drugs of choice were alcohol
primarily and cocaine and I've been
sober six and a half years can you go a
bit deeper into how it all started for
you I'm actually Irish despite my
horrible English accent but um so I grew
up in Ireland where there's no such
thing as an alcoholic it's just a guy
that likes a drink and my father
um who I don't have a relationship with
anymore I haven't for a long time is as
far as I'm worse still a chronic Gambler
very violent and abusive individual also
an alcoholic my childhood me and Matthew
Brothers we just had an horrific
childhood and full of domestic violence
full of screaming shouting things being
smashed more than being beaten up
we were beating up as well as children
and we suffered what known as Aces which
I'm sure you're all aware of adverse
child experiences a lot of trauma a lot
of pain it was actually alcohol when I
was about 16 but I never really liked it
because I assumed that if I drunk
alcohol I ended up like my father and I
didn't want to be that person at all
so
didn't really take to alcohol but I did
take to drugs so I tried cocaine which
was my first drug that I tried and to be
honest I loved it for the first few
years the honeymoon period lasted a good
few years and then I realized that I was
an addict whether I was in a good mood
or a bad mood or it was sunny or it was
raining I needed cooking to to survive
to get up and go to work and that was
what's called a functioning addict
um but then
I was around about 19 20. I got
introduced probably no sorry about 18 19
um I tried ketamine for the first time
which was quite a popular drug with the
people that I sort of associated myself
with and I instantly got hooked straight
away and for me what it did was it just
numbed me
um I always felt very very insecure very
unsure about who I was and who I wanted
to be I also had you know massive
underlining issues trust issues
relationship issues I had issues around
I never felt loved by my father in
particular and I always felt that that
was my fault I always felt that
the um abuse and Trauma I went through
as a child I believed that it was
because of me I felt I was worthless and
I was just a worthless piece I didn't
deserve anybody's love so I had a very
complex
um mind I guess at the time
and we kept him in it just shut it all
up and you know I'd have bumps of keys
um and then that drastically got worse
and worse and
that lasted for uh God until I was 32
years old and had a very highly
successful career throughout that period
as well there was bits and bats where I
was way worse than what I was
um but then I Was Made redundant in 2018
I lost my apartment I'd just come out of
a long-term relationship and I'd lost
everything
um and I
I just went out of control and I was
using from probably a gram Academy and
would last me and two of my friends
maybe two nights out to snorting
um anything from an ounce or it was a
day so like 24 Grand 28 grams okay I
mean
um and then I made two decisions I gave
myself two choices
which was
um in 2018 at the end of the year I was
either going to take my life which I
tried a few times and obviously it
wasn't successful
um
or I fix it and I really fix it
um so it was all or nothing for me it
was either deaf which I was dying anyway
you know I was using that much drugs to
the extent I lost like half my body
weight I was six Stone I looked like
what you would imagine a stereotypical
drug addict to look like
um even though I knew looked like that
for a very short period throughout my
addiction and um I worked my ass off to
get into real did six months six and a
half months in rehab and around about
nine months in their resettlement
program which is called re-entry and
then after that
um I guess the rest is Hitch it's this
history and I stopped using any kind of
drug any kind of substance anything
that's particularly addictive
um I believe that recovery is abstinence
and I just keep it as simple as that I
didn't experience anything unlike many
children do in families but I was a
sensitive person
um
I now know that I'm autistic I didn't
know that then
um but I felt things very much
and when I first started using Alcohol
and Other Drugs which I encountered
about 14 unknowingly to me I used those
as a coping mechanism to just take the
edge off my feelings prior to that I had
an eating disorder
which I only mentioned because there's a
common theme going on there I just
wanted to control how I felt what I
understand today about alcohol
specifically is it kind of breaks the
little synapses between
your neurons so you just think a bit
less you know you're just you're not
chronically over analyzing everything
all the time and
I found it easier to just be on the same
level as everyone else and I found it
easier to bond with other people
um I started running into trouble with
cocaine first I was at that point early
20s and I was using about four or five
grams of cocaine a day sometimes more
obviously financially you know that is a
quite difficult to maintain and there
are a lot of medical emergencies
ambulances heart problems things like
that
eventually I got myself to a point where
every time I use that substance I
there have been ambulance so just that
bit of classical conditioning made me
put that down a little bit and I thought
well I just I just drink drinking's
normal everyone does that that's cool
and I think I was about 23.
when I started just just picking up the
Vodka a lot more regularly and putting
down the cocaine and by 26 I didn't have
a home I didn't have
any money I had no dignity
um there were a lot of suicide attempts
I was very aggressive arrested
fights beating up my own dad
you know it it took me very quick
alcohol did and
um someone came around my house and
someone my mum had been speaking to I
wasn't in contact with my mum but she'd
been speaking to a colleague and this
colleague came out my house and because
I was so desperate I'd literally just
had another suicide attempt and another
ambulance and I was just so scared to be
in my own company I didn't want to start
drinking again but I had no other choice
that was my only coping mechanism for
all the pain that I was in it was the
first
um
conversation I'd had
and uh bearing in mind I walked into
counselors I'd walked into
you know doctors and you know I couldn't
really figure out what was wrong but I
didn't have the words and no one seemed
to be able to help because I couldn't
articulate what it was
um and that was the first conversation
I'd had with someone who
kind of laughed at my stories in a sense
of yeah I've done that yeah yeah same
yeah I've done that and there was this
woman like very well-to-do women put
together I mean she'd brush her hair and
put makeup on like she'd just come out
of a job
and um it took me a while I think it
took me about a year but at 27
um
I got sober
I think one thing I say about recovery
is that yeah you put the thing down
that's cool but that is the beginning
it's a real journey it's a real like
process
um my issue is I guess more behavioral
than substance based and
gambling which was my primary addiction
wasn't part of my life at all until I
was 19 years old unlike a lot of
addicts
my childhood was pretty idyllic
I was very high achieving I was very
fortunate in my background my education
I had everything you could possibly want
I suppose
and then at University
um
which is where gambling started for me I
was a professional Sportsman at the time
um and I got introduced to gambling
the first bet I ever placed was on a
roulette machine in a betting shop in
Durham
um and it won
and I can never explain the feeling that
I got from that moment
and the irony as I spent the next 13
years trying to replicate the feeling
that that moment gave me unsuccessfully
um and I wasn't addicted immediately but
I was hooked I loved it and not a day
went past for the next 13 years where I
didn't gamble
again like we've just heard
it wasn't a problem at first it was
money that I could afford to lose it was
time that I had to do it and then a year
later my Cricket career came to an end
and people experienced trauma in
different ways and means different
things to different people but that
moment in my life
was huge because
suddenly I'd gone from having everything
I wanted being everything that I wanted
to having lost that and that moment hit
me really hard and and then my
relationship with gambling changed
completely because it started to play a
different role in my life
I then moved into London
um I got a very good job in the city
working in finance and I started to do
it more and more
the culture and environment that around
surrounded me was all about having money
and having as much as you possibly can
and I wanted it
I worked even harder and then in 2010 a
year into my time in London and one
night I went out to celebrate some good
news at work
um I put a bet on and that night I won
35 000 pounds
from a football accumulator
and it sounds like the best thing that
could ever happen to anybody
um but it was without doubt the worst
thing that happened to me because
again it was another change in my
relationship with this drug
because now every time I did it
I wanted to win 35 000 pounds and if I
didn't it didn't give me the same
feeling
and I tried to do it every time
I didn't tell a single person in the
world that I won that money that night
which I guess shows how much problem it
was
but I lost there in a matter of four
weeks and when it was gone I wanted it
back
um and of course then I started to feel
different things I started to feel
guilty embarrassed ashamed stupid
and I started to combat those feelings
by drinking a lot of alcohol by taking
drugs because they were the only things
that made me forget about what was going
on my gambling and I started to do
things that obviously I will regret
forever because I started to borrow
money once all the
pay their loans credit cards bank loans
had run out started to borrow money off
individuals who had huge amounts of
money that I was connected to by lying
to them
I promised fan back I didn't pay a penny
back or gamble it all away and
I knew at some point I was going to get
found out I just didn't know when that
was going to be
but my biggest issue is I couldn't
handle
the shame and the stigma
that was attached to it
um and then in 2018 it all came to a
head
um
when my employers found out what was
going on and I knew at that point
um I was going to lose everything my
house my job
once that had happened
as was said earlier I had two choices
and I think the irony of a gambling
addiction which is probably a little bit
different to other addictions is
the only thing you think is ever going
to solve it is a thing that's caused it
in the first place because I don't think
any alcoholic ever tries to drink
themselves sober
but as a gambling addict you think all I
need to do is win the money back get rid
of the financial problem and then I can
stop and I tried
um
coincidentally it was the start of the
Cheltenham horse racing Festival
um
and I had about half a million pounds
worth of gambling debt and I honestly
believed I could just gamble more out
the problem and I tried I borrowed some
money off somebody
that had already borrowed money off told
them another lie I'm not very proud of
and during that Festival I I tried to
win the money back
um I won I lost and then eventually I
knew time was running out so I decided
to put the money that I'd built up over
the three days on one bet one horse and
one horse race the Cheltenham Gold Cup
in March 2018 and I said to myself if
that horse wins I'll win that money back
I'll pay everybody back I'll stop
gambling
I don't lose my house and my well I
might lose my house and my job but I
don't go to prison which I thought was
going to happen but life can continue
and if it doesn't win then I'm gonna go
and do the unthinkable
I watched my horse come second by a
couple of lengths and my whole world
come crashing down and
I don't need to go into too much detail
but I very I attempted I'm 10 million
life in various different ways and then
eventually ended up at a train station
um was moments away from killing myself
and then something changed and it was at
that moment that I thought about other
people not just myself
um and I'd hit the self-destruct button
for so long I thought so little of
myself
but I thought I can't do this to other
people and at that point I reached out
to my my brother
I told him what I was about to do and
unfortunately for me he responded in a
way that I wasn't expected expecting and
changed everything because he basically
said to me look
I should be honest
don't do what you're about to do
because he said that he wouldn't be able
to cope and he said look just tell me
what's going on and we'll find a way out
um
and weirdly I stood back and
the way the world had dropped off my
shoulders I'd finally told someone I had
this problem that I couldn't deal with
myself
and I could get the help that deep down
I knew I was desperate for and I had
been for a long time and
I came clean to my family everybody
I lost my house my job
but I went to rehab
um and I got the help that I needed so
my I started gambling just on a one-off
bet on the football I don't I don't even
watch football but um my stepdad he he
likes to you know watch a game and put a
bet on he's not a huge Gambler or
anything like that but I was at a loose
end on this particular day and um I was
being nosy and I was like what are you
doing and he told me so I was like oh
I'm gonna have a go at that you know so
I I put a bet on the football I knew
nothing about I just guessed and the BET
one
so that made me feel like wow I'm so
good at this so I had um some money in
my account
um and I explored the website to see
what else I could ever go on
and um I came across the slots and you
know I it was from when I found them
slots that's what really got me hooked
you know when I started winning
feeling was just like I've never felt
something so good in my life like wow
to the point like you know I started
losing then and I couldn't accept that I
could accept that I wasn't winning
anymore so I would constantly Chase
everything that I've lost
um even if I did have a big win or
something that was never enough I would
just convince myself oh I'll spend half
of it and then literally get down to
zero and you know
made me feel depressed
um yeah I didn't see any friends I
didn't text anybody I didn't nothing I
just was by myself getting depressed in
this world of my own which in a way I'd
quite liked you know because I I could
never handle emotions you know like I I
would always you know I'm autistic as
well
um I I can't you know I can't show if
I'm sad I can't show if I'm do you know
what I mean and I always thought it was
wrong so when I was gambling I was in
this world and nothing else existed no
other feelings nothing
um you know I got to the point where
actually I think the only way out is to
not be alive anymore
um
you know I had no self-worth I had no
confidence nothing and I couldn't
imagine my life without gambling
so at this point I didn't know that you
could be addicted to gambling I didn't I
didn't know it was a thing
um so I yeah I had a look online and I I
came across
um
Gordon Moody and I applied to go on
their women's retreat which was Retreat
and counseling program it wasn't
residential
so I did that and you know that was
amazing you know they saved my life I
learned all about my addiction and you
know
I learned about myself I learned you
know it's okay to be upset it's okay to
you know feel
unhappy but as long as you're dealing
with these things
um I was getting through managing and my
hair started to fall out because of the
stress from the gambling this made me
feel really depressed you know I didn't
even know how to cope with hair loss you
know because it you know hair especially
for a woman a woman you know what I mean
it's like wow it's a big thing isn't it
um and
so I had a major relapse I was I didn't
know how to cope to be honest and I
didn't care either I started gambling
again you know I was hiding it I got you
know I isolated myself again
um got to the point where you know I I
want you to not be alive again and and I
something clicked and I just thought
right I need to reach out for help again
so I did and thankfully they took me
back on the program
um and yeah I managed to you know be on
track
um stay non you know stay stop myself
from gambling and then I was referred on
to
um
the Epic restart Foundation who I'm
fortunate enough to be working for now I
think you know as a woman who is in
recovery from gambling I think it's
important to share my story and you know
just reassure people that there are
there is plenty of help out there and
you know you're not on your own there's
nothing to be ashamed about at all
for me I include lots of things into the
addiction bracket that I know not
necessarily everybody would
um for me it started expressing itself
when I was about 14 15 I developed an
eating disorder and I mentioned that to
say because
um I almost was addicted to the numbers
the weight loss it wasn't even that I
didn't want to be skinny like I was
naturally very small but it was this
this thing that I could quantify that I
could see it drop and it gave me like
some form of Serotonin boost when it
went down and
you know this it's this thing of my life
for a long time was this game of
um emotional whack-a-mole
where you know I beat the I beat the
eating disorder and then I started
self-harming and then I'd stopped
self-harming and then it was always this
like if you imagine like a little
toddler it's always like grabby hands
onto something that would just make me
feel a little bit better and I
discovered alcohol when I was maybe 15
16. I was always known for being
incredibly shy
that was like my whole branding like
when I did TV and stuff it was just oh
she's the shy girl you know
um but it wasn't shyness it was um
self-hatred
portrayed in an almost palatable way
where I didn't speak because I felt like
I didn't have anything to offer
um I I would never look people in the
eye I never wanted to again that burden
feeling I never wanted to burden anybody
um but for me alcohol then
became this way of
me having fun for the first time getting
drunk
allowed me to not overthink not
that tape that was always playing in the
back of my head that was you're
worthless you're awful if anybody knew
how awful of a person you are
they would cast you away that that tip
that was always playing Just
shut off and stopped
and I I could I could do things that I
would never be able to do sober at the
time which was like you know dance laugh
be uh outward be all of the things that
I always in the inside wanted to be and
it was always reinforced as well by
people that I would hang out with that
they're like oh you're such a fun drunk
and what started off as like a bottle of
wine and having a little dance around my
room and singing into my hairbrush
quickly turned into turning up to the
studio hungover
trying to do a vocal after I've just
been sick in the bathroom and
basically by 20 I'd reached
an absolute Breaking Point
emotionally
that realization that the
the pain that I was putting myself
through wasn't
comfortable
it was just familiar
and I went to my first ever AAA meeting
and it was an old woman's meeting on a
Saturday
and I walk into this room obviously all
I'd ever seen was the things you see on
TV and it's like dark Smoky rooms with
like old men and that's you know and it
was not that it was
all these beautiful women with amazing
personalities laughing joking and I sat
there and I heard someone share their
story and it resonated
but what I latched on to was the
the thing that was weighing me down that
made life unbearable that made me try to
take my life on multiple occasions this
thing that possessed me and owned me
they were laughing about it and I was
like where we can do that we can joke
about this
realize that for me
AAA and meetings are great but I have
um psychological things going on I've
you know everyone has their own traumas
to unpack and deal with but
through that journey of not only just
doing that approach but also
going and getting a psychiatrist
going and getting a therapist and all of
these things I find out that I have
um borderline personality disorder I'm
bipolar and well ADHD as well for some
spice but from addressing that I
realized that these addictive patterns
these addictive behaviors come from
a condition that I have and it's a
symptom of a condition that I have I
used to hate using the scapegoat mental
health but I started to kind of notice
that I was different uh
so
um my mind would be telling me that I
have to do certain things to make sure
I'm okay my family are okay and I've
later on found out that it's basically
severe a severe form of OCD
uh all my friends were smoking cannabis
and stuff like that but I you know I
didn't bother doing that type of stuff
and then in year 10 year 11 of high
school
it got really bad it just it just got to
a point where you know I thought I'm
gonna try and smoke a spliff I have a
little drink with my mates which you
know in them times if you don't do that
you kind of left out anyway like so I
wanted to fit in with them anyway they
were all drinking and stuff and I just
started doing it myself so um
yeah the drink was fine but then when I
started trying the Cannabis I came I
became this kid who was like you know
would never touch it you know scared to
touch it because I might die to end up
being the person who was like the
biggest weed smoker out of all my mates
and it became very
obsessive very quickly you know to the
point where I was selling my personal
belongings for weed you know and during
that time my uncle came out of prison he
was just you out of prison and although
he's done this this crime he was 10 feet
tall to me I actually thought he was
like the coolest man on Earth
you know and uh I started hanging around
with him because I stopped hanging
around with my my friends I felt very
lonely and I I didn't know I just
gravitated to him
and very quickly I was exposed to a life
of just yeah just wild stuff stuff I
never you know I was never exposed to
before
um started drinking started taking
cocaine taking pills buying a pre-goblin
whatever anything weed I could get my
hands on to kind of take away
my OCD kind of traits and also just to
kind of get over I've just broke up
friends with my best mate and at the
time it felt like it was just nothing
this you know this will blow over and
everything will be fine again
yeah I got to one stage when I was out
one night with a friend who I knew from
school I we were taking cocaine and I
went back to the the flat where my
uncle's kind of Base was and his friends
and he were all in there and they were
all
smoking something on a can of Coke
and I knew what it was because I seen it
anyway for so long when I was hanging
around with them and uh
yeah someone offered me some and I took
some and uh
yeah it was it's hard to explain it's
like taking cocaine but it's like you
know it it hitting you instantly
[Music]
um and the rush is just unbearable like
you can't speak your ears are ringing
it's just this intense feeling
and
um yeah like it was amazing
quickly I would say less than a minute
after taking that I started to get these
bad effects side effects kind of the
side effects I got when I was smoking
the weed you know cocaine's a stimulant
and it was really kind of magnifying my
thoughts without my OCD
and I started kind of praying it out a
little bit and someone said oh I have a
puff of this and it was a spliff and I
thought well if I smoke that's going to
make me ten times worse
it's not weed it's not weed it's it's
it's gear he said it was gear which was
Halloween
I was just looking for some anything at
the time to just take away the feeling I
was feeling that that panic and um yeah
yeah I just said yeah let me have a perf
and I took two drugs of the spliff and
uh
yeah that was that was it that was
that's how everything started for me
um it took away everything it was like
the keys to everything I've been asking
unlocked
and that's when the prison started
that's when the offending started and uh
yeah I became a shoplifter who would
travel up down the country
every single day uh
and it's like we say we we we we
spend all we used to the last great
don't we you know I'd make thousands
hundreds a day and in the morning I'm
waking up asking someone for a cigarette
like you know it's like because it all
had to go on on the drug
and
um after you know I think I've been in
jail over 10 times all for the same
stuff all petty crime just to fund my
habit
um
2020 came around which was
coronavirus yeah the worst year for a
lot of people you know uh ended up being
the best year of my life because
um I made a lot of money shoplifting I'm
joking that's not really no well I did
actually because
no it was it actually was I'll tell you
what because I was allowed to wear a
mask and no one would question me you
know and people would go nowhere near me
when I was going in the shops because
they thought I had covid you know so
I made a lot of money during lockdown
but
if you make a lot of money as an addict
what are you gonna do you're gonna smoke
it all in you and you know the more
money the more I abuse the drug and it
got to a point where my body couldn't
take it no more and my my close friends
my
my partner in crime I should say
he passed away
um and the same day he passed away I was
rushed into Hospital
I almost died as well
when I was in the hospital and I
actually thought I was going to die like
it was to the point where if I try
taking my my gas mask off I was kind of
going out of contract I couldn't breathe
without this mask
and I I prayed to a higher power like I
I'm not religious and I know we're in a
within a religious setting right now
maybe maybe you're saying something but
I pray to a higher power and I just said
please let me get through this and I
promise I will never I will never use
again you know that was my rock bottom
is addiction a choice or is it an
illness for me I don't believe it's a
disease at all
um and I struggled in rehab one with
that belief and when I first went to
rehab
I'd never used heroin or crack so I used
to automatically think that I wasn't as
bad as a junkie or a crackhead even
though I was a kitten I'll show you all
the picture I used to look like I was
sick Stone and nearly dead I do believe
that recovery is is different for the
individual but for me I do believe in
abstinence which I guess is is a
fundamental approach the 12 steps and I
just don't believe it's a disease I
don't believe I was born with some
biological or genetical predisposition
that
um
that determine that I would be an addict
I believe I grew up in the right
environment that created a lot of
wouldn't mean I would run away and
escape and I found drugs as a form of
escapism I think addiction starts with a
choice but a lot of people can't make a
informed Choice yeah
um
but I know that the gambling was down
ultimately down to me it was me that
placed that bet and I have to take for
me personally I have to take
responsibility in my recovery I can't
blame other things in other people
um there are external factors that
definitely played a part and could have
done more or could have done less but
ultimately
it's about me I always acquired at the
whole disease thing of my bed extreme
but I I understand why they use it and I
also understand
that that whole people have
controversies with the 12-step because
of God and all of this kind of stuff but
I think psychologically it's very
interesting because realistically an
addict is living their life very
selfishly it's a very selfish lifestyle
you're not considering anybody else but
yourself right so by going hey God
whatever you want it to be I remember
when I went to recovery there was a
woman who believed in the Bumblebees
that was her God and I was like okay
cool that's whatever you want it to be
as long as it's not you and as long as
it's it's not another person it can God
is whatever you want it to be in
recovery
um but psychologically it makes the
addict not see themselves as the center
of their own universe that it's not thy
will be done you know it's not it's my
world you know it's it tries to remove
themselves from that and I find
I I don't care uh you know taking
accountability
um for what I've done but I the the
whole notion of choice I find
particularly difficult because I am of
an age where in school we had all the
drug programs all the people coming in
and sharing their stories every single
workbook every single Friday we were
doing something to do with
sex drugs alcohol all the things but
someone can have all the education
and old and knowing
but it's not going to stop it yeah and
when we over pathologize
addiction and Recovery to things like if
we just tell people more and if we just
do this and we just do this it's going
to take this problem away
addiction is going to continue to exist
yeah I think you had a really uh
personal point in the fact that when you
were telling your story you were saying
you know you classify yourself as an
addict because it's kind of anything we
touch isn't it it doesn't have to be
drugs
or alcohol I'm stealing this from a
psychologist gabo mate who I'm
absolutely obsessed with okay I'm
meeting him next month no me yeah so I'm
gonna be make friends with you
um yeah so he kind of says like
Addiction in itself
is not necessarily genetic I.E an
illness which is inherited
but you can have certain predispositions
in your nature
what I find amongst my peers as addicts
and what I've picked up from some of
your stories is that whatever you've
used or behaviorally done is to escape
from your feelings right so
my emotions take my whole body I am my
emotions like that I can't
compartmentalize my emotions very well
that is part of my my character
that potentially is inherited right
environment yes I was around drugs when
I was young I had friends that did drugs
that made me feel good so I'm going to
fixate so exercise you know that's been
one and that was in recovery it was
saying yeah and you get a pause for it
absolutely well yeah these are looking
after yourself you look amazing yeah
workaholism I'm dying yeah well done you
made money like yeah so
while I don't think I was born a drug
addict or alcoholic and addiction in
itself
I think it's quite dangerous to just
lump addiction as as an illness because
then you're not you're ignoring the
thinking and the and the uh emotionality
and the things that are going to come up
after you put the drug or alcohol down I
believe that everyone's recovery is
different and I think the way you we get
on drugs and the way we come off it is
totally different different support
structures the way we think's different
um I don't stand for 12 steps myself
I've not a fan of it um I think they
ostracize everyone else who doesn't do
12 steps
um yeah yeah yes and this ain't got
bigger better here for it because I did
I did up to like step four and I was
like yeah I I I'll go to meetings and
I'll do this and yeah take what you want
from me like you know and they're like
oh you haven't done them and they're
like almost they stand back and kind of
do it yeah yeah can't wait for you to
fall exactly
I've been invited to so many talks can
you sit at the chair I don't even know
what the chairman yeah
no oh you can't sit at the chair yeah
recovery is recovery
and not always
yeah I travel too far to turn around
yeah yeah I've tried it and they're like
I do think we all have addictive
personalities or well ones who have felt
to addiction we are addictive
personalities right now I am just fully
focused on achieving in my life and I'm
addicted to that you know and when I say
illness disease I'm just talking about
some people who identify that you know
but it's an easy way of saying it it's
an easy way yeah yeah you know I think I
was probably born with an addictive
personality and I've just been
hyperventilated on different things and
I just managed to pick up the pipe and
the foil at one stage in my life
understanding the recovery is is what
works for you yeah yeah and what works
for you might not work for somebody else
but if it works for you then keep doing
it 12 steps works for probably lots of
people
but not everyone that works for me but
not and I I hear people about meetings
saying trying just to be in recovery to
say you've got it you've got to keep
doing that
for some people they do for other people
they don't or they may they may do for
the first year or
is whatever works for you
um and I I think it's it's really
important that people understand that
and if you're not doing what everybody
else is doing it it doesn't matter
what's also important to think about for
me because it's that the opposite of
addiction isn't sobriety that it's
connection yeah and that goes back to
everyone knows the famous Like Cocaine
rat you know where they they did the
study where they put the rats in the
cage and they'd always go back to the
cooking
they redid that study with another cage
not just cocaine and no cocaine they put
a little ratopia in there so they had a
little girlfriend rat little like lovely
Wheels lovely fun things that I can go
and do and it's having a good time
and the cocaine was there
and the rat never went yeah because it's
got the occupied it's got nice things
going on it's got relationships it's got
fun it's got drive it's got things to
keep it going and when you when you put
your we always with a lot of addicts and
I'm sure most people can relate to that
is when you're in addiction you are
isolated you're cutting yourself off
from every relationship to any
meaningful Communications with people
any connection whatsoever and then it's
like oh I wonder why I'm drinking myself
to death and using myself or doing
whatever to death and it's like because
what else have you got going on a lot of
the things I've read were about
all addiction is almost always a cross
addiction yeah
I think whack-a-mole was mentioned and
for me the goal of all this is balance
right so you're you're constantly going
to be doing a bit of this
but the whole goal for me anyway
what symbolizes recovery for me
is not
one extreme of like perfectly sober not
doing anything meditating meditating on
a mountain and that's it
are not smash drunk doing cocaine like
in a city basement somewhere it's
kind of somewhere in the middle
of
the two extremes of anything that I'll
usually go to some people have that some
people innately have that I've got
friends that are naturally quite
balanced
um
but but me it's a constant effort and
one of the I think one of the most just
to pick up on what you said one of the
most powerful
tools gifts and recoveries
self-awareness yeah my my addictive
personality I've stopped gambling but my
addictive personality still exists
hugely and it manifests itself in all
sorts of weird and wonderful ways and
people have already said about
addicted to exercise
and they're things that are more
acceptable and you kind of get a plot
but it's about as you said the balance
but it's also having the awareness that
it's something that you could lose
control with or could get out of control
and my mum used to see it you've got an
addictive personality Jim I never did I
wish I could get addicted to the gym
if you went there you know that's how
it's not a choice
so yeah like addiction is you know for
me I was very much addicted to the
Escape
element of it
um I think I definitely have the
potential to you know at the time I was
drinking a lot of alcohol so that was
that was potentially another addiction
that I could have gone down that road
and like when I was at school for
instance I would drink alcohol because I
I wasn't okay with myself you know I had
no confidence so I would drink to get
that it makes me feel Brave you know
what I mean I could be I couldn't accept
who I was basically I didn't know who I
was and I didn't fit in anywhere so you
know I think I do have an addictive
personality I think now going through
recovery in gambling I think
it's about finding healthier escapes for
myself and you know accept who I am it's
that thing I think like cross addiction
if you're pinning it on one substance or
another substance or like this behavior
and that substance
you're kind of missing the point like
it's it's the underlying drive to get
out of myself to get away from myself to
escape to find safety because there is
no happiness or safety in here but for
me when I really reflected upon what I
was doing it was I just wanted to feel
comfortable yeah I hate using with
normal but like I wanted to feel
comfortable with myself because every
day when I used to wake up I hated
looking and even when I didn't look like
particularly like an addict I hated
myself even if I dress nice or hung
around with good looking people or
whatever like I always felt like
horrible and ugly and I don't mean
aesthetically inside I felt disgusted
and always guilty and shameful of
um who I was and why I was like I was
but when I went through rehab and all
that allowed you know it allowed me one
of the things to do was to learn about
myself and actually to feel comfortable
you know I think about using all the
time I don't know if any of you think
about gambling or drinking but
it's my biggest fear and I still think
I'm always sometimes
um and I'm scared of that weird relapse
like I'm a bit scared of it and I don't
know if it's because I'm scared of that
I try and not agree with that word but I
think when someone says the word relapse
you put back the square one yeah you
remove any progress yeah yeah not not
yeah like yeah when it's not necessarily
like that I mean it's not like it's like
snakes and ladders they just go oh back
to zero well yeah well you you know
PlayStation's got memory cards now
anything yeah man we can go back to
where he was yeah that's how I feel
though back in the day you'd have a mega
drive if the electric
memory cards in it you know what I mean
we should be able to go back to
everything we've learned everything
we've achieved and yeah that's how I
look at blips I call them
yeah
it's never positive or negative there's
always
and people relapse they think that's it
I might as well just carry on or
generally that's what people probably
think but then also if you can learn in
that and come back better and stronger I
relate to you in the sense that um I
don't really think about alcohol anymore
as such I do especially going through
quite deep emotional pain over the past
like two years I very often wish I had a
way to turn off and that's what I'm
really wanting when I want alcohol you
know like it doesn't I think sometimes
it's also really important that people
don't become in recovery they don't
become too obsessed with how long
they've been in recovery because that
scares a lot of people when it comes to
relapsing yeah because suddenly if you
relapse you're starting again
there are other people who say I've been
clean sober for 20 years and it becomes
a competitive thing and yeah I think if
you are somebody who
is in recovery and you have relapsed I
think it's really important that you
don't become too obsessed upon that do
you think that addiction manifests
differently in men and women with the
the stigma that is attached to certain
addictions and I think Joe would talk
about this gambling
often seen as very male dominated
problem issue things that a thing that
blokes do more than women if I'm allowed
to say that and so therefore if you're
somebody who's struggling with it it's
probably harder to get help just like
with
Eating Disorders I know a lot of guys
that have very serious eating disorders
but won't talk about it because it's a
problem that women have yeah and I think
I don't think that personnel and there's
a difference you've got an addiction
you're a drug addict you're an alcoholic
you're
a compulsive Gambler whatever it is but
it's what's perhaps some of these kind
of preconceived your ideas or
stereotypes yeah that mean actually it's
probably harder to do something about it
that I think is probably more of a
problem than it actually being different
whether you're a manner so you see in
the men and women equally have Eating
Disorders but it's harder for a man to
open up I I think yeah yeah I think
there might be some sort of cultural or
social like swinging more towards
acceptable addictions for a male or a
female but the thing about addiction is
which is weirdly enough what I find
beautiful but also very worrying is the
fact that we discriminate addicts or
being addicts whatever the addiction
whatever whatever it is the device or
whatever but addiction doesn't
discriminate it doesn't care what color
you are what religion you are what sex
you are yes you know your gender or
sexual orientation it literally doesn't
give a fit yeah apart from all it cares
about is that you give it everything
that you love and cherish there are
equal numbers of men and women say in
alcoholism recovery
um
you know but it's actually quite
dangerous the way stereotypes are
because I'm chugging away at my vodka
you know there's no way in hell I'm
becoming an alcohol alcoholic I'm a
young woman
um drinking in a bag well yeah drinking
in a bar if I was like Yeah The
Stereotype of an alcoholic did not fit
my image at all so it got way too far
would advise would you give someone
who's in an access stage of addiction
right now I have a loved one who's in an
active stage it's never too late yeah
yeah that that cliche word like you know
two three years into my addiction as I
had room and addict a junkie you smack
Aid I didn't think I would ever change
my life I never thought I'd have a a
beautiful partner a family my friends
back a paid job I've got a criminal
record I think my DBS was that thick
when it came back
I've got a pay job like a legit job you
know I go around speaking to say I speak
to people who once hated me police
officers and stuff like that you know
and they're taking in and trying to
understand my story
um being allowed in schools the only
place I haven't been yet is the prisons
I'm trying to get in there but you know
not back there obviously yeah the other
way
I said it earlier like I definitely
encourage anybody
reach out for help don't suffer on your
own you're not on your own there's
plenty of support out there and we're
sitting here as proof that you can
recover
um and there's nothing to be ashamed
about whatsoever
for me I think what I would say to
someone in Act of addiction is just you
you deserve
to be sober you deserve to have a life
that you
like yourself at the bare minimum you
deserve to be happy
and yeah just the the core you actually
deserve it when I first got into
recovery and I was in rehab
I couldn't even say because I'm worth it
it wouldn't come out of my mouth
but you are every single human being on
this planet is deserving of love and
deserves to be happy and deserves to
again at the bare minimum like yourself
you know and that you gotta you gotta do
it for yourself like yeah I I tried to
stop
13 years I try to stop
God knows how many times
But ultimately I wasn't ready to stop
and there's a big difference if you're
in active addiction of saying you want
to stop and actually stopping yeah and
you you really do it's not easy you got
it takes a lot of Bravery a lot of
Courage a lot of time
a lot of determination but you have to
really want to do it and you have to
commit to it
um and it gets easier but
somebody said it earlier
you can't do it because other people
want you to do it
um
because that doesn't work it's got to
come from you and there's got to be a
real desire to
get out of it and there is always a way
out there's help
talking is so important but you've got
to want to do it I get a lot of people
contact me online as I said earlier and
I think for if you're someone that that
loves an addict of any kind the only one
thing that you can really do is hope and
you can hope that they can change their
lives as we've all established and said
numerous times we can't force anybody to
change no um and I tried that for a
little bit myself I sort of became like
a little during lockdown of coach for
recovery and I had this sort of Messiah
complex that I thought I could speak to
anybody and change their lives and I was
so wrong and so so wrong
um thankfully I only did it for a little
while before I realized it was probably
more about my own eager
um but you can't change anybody
um if you love someone that's in pain
you can't change them unfortunately but
all you need to do is love them and if
you are an addict
um
for me it's pretty simple
um two things believe that you can do it
and stop making excuses because if you
think about our lives and our
experiences every time you thought about
getting sober or clean or stop gambling
you thought oh but what but but what if
I need to do this first I need to win
that money back or another gram or 10
grams or an ounce won't hurt you know I
need it because it's raining or because
it's like that's all of that is is
and anything other than that is
an excuse so stop making excuses and I
know that sounds really bullet and
horrible but I think the faster you come
to that realization of anything other
than that than working on your problems
is an excuse yeah guys you're so amazing
honestly this is just listening to this
so beautiful do you do you think
I mean it's kind of like part of like a
lot of like obviously group therapy
groups but do you think I feel like a
minimum
yeah
literally have you been content
my therapist make you guys come here
yeah does it but does it help does it
help talking to other addictions to be
honest like I think like this was really
I really enjoyed this and gonna go away
and remember you guys now like this
conversation here is amazing yeah and it
stops you from getting complacent as
well because sometimes it's so easy to
go oh that's in the past I'm not an
addict anymore and then it will sneak up
on you a little bit whereas having
conversations with other addicts
just reminds you that oh God yeah I was
actually that bad and oh okay I wasn't
that bad but that's a yet because I
could get that bad and yeah
and it just and also it's just like oh
it's not that bad being an addict is
actually the best thing that ever
happened to me another other addicts are
ultimately the only people that
understand yeah you and what you're
feeling yeah yeah and earlier like when
I first stopped people said oh I
understand how difficult it was I know
you don't and nor should you yeah it's
not your fault but actually
that understanding that Mutual
connection is yeah that's so powerful
[Music]
have you ever killed someone and how did
that feel
it's a tough one yeah
me personally as a sniper yes I have
what did it feel like to begin with and
felt I was in trouble